today's topic i seen a post where i was
like oh
if you wanna take me out he gotta pay
for my babysitter why should my baby
daddy and me gotta pay for my babysitter
when you don't wanna take me out what
i'm not gonna ask to be oh pay for my
babysitter i'm expecting you to know to
do that for me
like if i'm like oh like i will go out
with you but i can't find a sitter
it's up to you to be like yo i really
want to take this girl out i'm about to
pay for her babysitter
so if i noticed that you didn't think to
do something like that or you ain't
trying to like work around that in
whichever way
i'm not yeah i'm not messing with you
but i'm
like rea and i'm telling you real like
women who live this lifestyle
they're not saying it they're expecting
it and then they weed you out
accordingly and that's the way it should
be done well i'll eat you out
accordingly too cause if you got kids
i got a question who raised y'all
most women actually because they're
single mothers they have a certain way
of thinking about man so they don't want
to rely
on men most women are not like that i'm
pretty sure that most women are not like
that but there's that little percentage
of you know
there was one girl who said i expect it
but i would never
ask for it you guys already know this
about me i would never ask
for the money or ask a man to pay for my
children
i would never ask because i'm just way
too prideful i would never ask
i would never ask for anything why
wouldn't you ask for it
cause i got too much pride oh you're too
proud
to ask for something that you feel you
deserve maybe it's because you feel
shame because you recognize it's a
shameful thing to ask for
do you guys have no shame no no you
brought a child into this world
you go on a first date and you expect
them to pay potentially for the food of
the child
and the babysitter it's just an
indication of like
how a lot of women want to live life on
easy mode people just be
hollering at people and dm's like you
trying to buy me a gucci bag you trying
to spend money on me
papi do you guys have no shame
do you have no shame it's a stranger
and then you got other people on the
other hand like well if you're trying to
date a single mom you're gonna need to
be this is the first date
yeah if you're trying to date me you got
to meet my parents right away what
why is your dad sitting beside you at
this table right now
that's the same logic yeah well if
you're trying to then you need to buy
that dad
uh new crutches because that [ __ ] old
and that's part of the family packing
abba it's just a happy meal it's not
about that it's not about five dollars
it's not about it it's the principles
yeah it's your child
how do you show up on a date your hair
done
your looks all done but your kid is not
fed
in my head i'm like your priorities are
trash
why don't you just cancel the date and
take care of your important stuff
which is your child being fed
rather than relying on somebody that you
haven't met yet
it's crazy it's like i guess some
browsers live on easy mode so hard
that they don't even have to put their
best foot forward they just take a
dookie in their hand and they throw it
on the table like the first step
that's what they doing they gotta get yo
they just take a dookie in their hand
they throw it on the floor and they're
like
first step alimony baby
alimony baby and [ __ ] just like
i'll take that shot okay after the last
video we did
i'm not gonna lie to you that just
shocked me so much i didn't realize that
was like a thing that people just think
oh it's a thing i've dated single moms
before
not one i owed of that kind of stuff
ever surfaced they never like you trying
to meet my kids they were never rushing
me
they was never being like can you pay
for this they handled their business
so for me and i never looked at them
sideways but i could never imagine i
understand
you know i mean it's not everybody i
wouldn't even say
that is the majority of people that go
like that but i'd say
i've got 30 percent of people 30 to 20
which is big where'd you get those
numbers from from i made itup.com
from being a bouncer and hear people in
conversation in line there's a lot of
things that you hear in conversation in
line with how people think
when you can't let them outside inside
the club yet you know what i mean
and then you start talking or you just
listen
and you're just like wow that dumb you
said right there
is the reason i'm not going to let you
in the club
is that i expect you to pay for the
babysitter
yes yes i'm late girl i listen the guy
didn't even wanna
i dropped him like i had to yeah i heard
that yay
where were you oh my god he didn't even
want to pay for the babysitter and stuff
like that so we had to argue so he left
so i had to bring my kids to my i'm not
saying it's the majority of people
like yo listen i already said this if i
ask a girl on a date i'm gonna pay for
the dinner
whether it's a 30 dinner 30 100 like i'm
fine with that that's like
i wanted to do that experience with this
person that's cool but the idea of the
child and me paying a new spring i'm
like
it sounds crazy to me pay for her pay
for her
babysitter but whatever what do you mean
i'm paying for a babysitter
who who who's this babysitter how much
does it cost do i get a tax slip like
what are we talking about right now
crazy bro yeah but like i said
it's a small percentage it's crazy
that's nuts you know what i mean like if
i showed up on a date with a bit of beer
i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] up you took a dookie in
your hand and threw it on the floor
and you're like that's that take in the
aromas and you don't care and you like
if you don't like the way the poop
smells
you cut from the teeth if you can't
smell the poop my dookie
then you can't be about this
relationship because i'm gonna take
dookies
in this bathroom you know what's wild is
they justify oh we traditional women we
want to be taken care of
[ __ ] even in the middle ages they took
showers before they showed up to the
date
how was your dirty snake ass in the
middle ponies
no they didn't which time no they didn't
talk about they didn't
shower you get the point hold up
nobody's showered you get the point they
put their best foot forward
right when you're gonna set up an
arranged marriage or anything like that
you put
yes [ __ ] perfume on the thing okay okay
right they put their best like they're
not just gonna show up
and they'll be like this is me and my
five bastards
you're like you know what i mean why
would your leg up
a [ __ ] because that's how i feel like
why the hell
was your leg why am i buying a four
dollar happy meal
what no i don't need it i'm triggered
bro i'm triggered
nah bro nah nah nah nah nah because
because no
you know what they said uh modern day
uh listen women we making cheddar we
live in our best life i
am dep but you paying for the date i was
like you know what i asked you out okay
i can see that why was your leg up nah
nah
nah nah nah i could see that i said you
know what i asked you out i'm gonna pay
and you're like
man she wants some chicken nuggets and
some fries
we understand that no no no
that's crazy okay whatever that's crazy
like hey man i got a babysitter i'm like
[ __ ] how many bills are we adding on
this [ __ ]
it's the first day am i paying for the
four-year-old
tick-tock bill like am i paying for her
tick-tock bill
do they have tick-tock bills i don't
think they have tick-tock yeah but
but her four-year-old needs to be
entertained while she's with me
nah bro what are we talking about it's
like first it was a meal
now i gotta pay for your kids meal then
i gotta pay for the babysitter what am i
paying next
what am i paying next for college fun
[ __ ] like what are we talking about
no you know this baby's gonna go to
college so you better get about this you
know what i mean what happened to
treating like a first date almost like a
job interview in the sense that you come
forward with your like bet you know your
nice outfit
you wear your perfume right you you know
you try to look
you present you know i don't know i
don't know this is this is really like a
come get me attitude
do everything in all the steps it's
entitlement
it's being entitled not everybody is a
small percentage but that on that part
[ __ ] gonna be like yeah you know
what all you need to pick up all my [ __ ]
up to get with me because you're gonna
keep on picking up
picking up my fuck-ups but at the end of
the day it's not everybody i'm telling
you 25 to 30 percent
it's like goddamn like you know what i
also realized when i saw this i'm like
man why do black folks got to be so
goddamn messy on social media bro
am i crazy no i said it yo
listen that's messy
okay that's a whole mess why is your
window wide open and everybody on the
street can see into your room
clean that [ __ ] up or close your
curtains you mean why is your window
open and we can see to the floor we
could see
to the wall to the sweat go down your
balls bruh
i don't know man all them [ __ ] and
people was defending that [ __ ] i was
like oh my god bro
you're not bro dog you can't keep them
off other dogs
i get i guess dating has changed maybe i
missed a missed a boat or two
i've never seen those stuff like that or
two listen i've been on youtube
no no no no no no i've been on some
interesting dates
it's not been that long but this
never that's a bad yeah that's a thing i
think that if it was something like that
there would be other things
there would be other things that before
you even get to the date you
talking to the person there would be
other things that makes you drop her so
you wouldn't have gone to the date
that's probably why the pre-screening
your pre-screening is pretty strong
so i don't think that that would happen
there's other things
that would have happened that you would
you would have dismissed it so that's i
think that's the reason why
you were not aware or you didn't
encounter that so that being said
there's some guys that are going to be
like well why do i attract all the uh
the same kind or even women are going to
say
why do i always attract yeah no you
don't attract you let people in
all right and that's pretty much [ __ ] so
maybe you don't even let
people like that in and that's why you
didn't know that existed
i just i don't know listen i was raised
by a single mother so
i just could never imagine her doing the
stuff like she just had so much pride
she handled her business and she worked
hard
and it made me respect her despite it
not being an eye like ideal environment
like she did her thing
i don't know if i would have looked at
her with respect to she out here trying
to fleece [ __ ] for food and
and and money for her babysitter like
i don't know i don't know just
some y'all something i need to to know
what it means to be ashamed
some shame is good game of thrones we
need to walk some people through the
street and just yell
shame at them want what
that's just in creole yo what
you know like i said maybe i missed some
y'all could let me know but i just can't
believe what i'm seeing
[Music]
oh um